hi
everyone still is talking about the
corona crisis which keeps spreading
around the world
and lots of places a second wave looms
while the pandemic is acute climate
change persists to likely be the global
challenge for humanity the question is
what can we as experts who employ
computers and computation to tackle
management
and public policy issues learn from such
crises and challenges
with due respect to the big data hype
but mainly looking
in the rearview mirror at lots of data
and fitting some standard black box
model to them
is doomed to fail us in strategic and
political decision support
most obviously when we do not have
sufficient data from the past
whenever we deal with a complex dynamic
system irrespective of it being a
natural system
or social system like an organization we
should consider
the system structure more explicitly
because it's
the structure that causes behavior
in gray box models we should instead
consider the main
components of a system under management
and their interconnections
as explicitly as necessary and may be
possible
putting that structure in a suitable
mathematical model
that can be analyzed by a computer will
then allow us to explain observed
behavior
and to predict behavior in the future to
test different policies
we should consider the importance of
transparency because we may have to
explain our decisions
to stakeholders and the public
in modeling technical systems we have
achieved a lot already and looking at
this modelica model
from the vehicle interfaces library you
may concur with me in noting the extreme
clarity and transparency
even though it is complex the model fits
on a single page
we can drill down into more detail
because the model is built in a
hierarchical fashion
the structure and nature of the real
system is immediately clear
the cyber physical modeling approach
nicely separates
the causal domain of control and the a
causal sphere of the physical system
where the same model component may be
reused in different contexts
we do not need to write equations
instead we can build this model
simply by dragging components onto a
canvas and then connecting them
how can this convenience be made
available for modeling social and
environmental systems
to support decision making
while there are many different methods
for modeling and simulation out there
we will now focus on system dynamics
which was invented by the mit
professor and electrical engineering
pioneer j white forester in the 1950s
system dynamics is especially suited to
support decision making in a strategic
management
or public policy context furthermore it
is capable
of integrating other modeling approaches
as well
at the heart of any model in system
dynamics there are the state variables
called stocks
reservoirs or levels as they are in
economics
these hold some kind of conserved matter
or simply entities
in a strategic business context we would
first of all think about a company's
resources
these may be tangible like capital
equipment inventories
or employees as well as intangible like
capabilities
reputation or information we may also
include loyal customers or competitors
resources and other important stocks
have to be grown and build over time
and they also deteriorate or are simply
lost
transitions of matter or entities are
modeled as in out or net
flows that work at a certain rate in
continuous time
again exactly as it is done in economics
we cannot simply double our customers or
employees in an instance
in the same vein reputation can be lost
quickly
but may take years to rebuild an
essential feature of system dynamics
is to explicitly model significant
delays
in any transition often we have what is
called an aging chain instead of just a
single stock
new employees will become more
experienced loyal customers
may become disloyal reliable capital
equipment will eventually become
unreliable and finally defective
the next step in modeling is to show how
resources
and other stocks determine the output or
performance of the system
we will then model how that information
is used for decision making which
directly or indirectly influences the
rates of growth
or decline in the system complexity
arises
because there are other influences as
well while we often blame exogenous
shocks
we tend to forget about internal
feedback within the system
this will become quite clear when we
look at the mother of all epidemic
models
the s-i-r model by kermig and mchenrik
a higher number of infected individuals
will raise the force of infection which
in turn
will lead to an increased number of
newly infected
we are thus looking at a reinforcing
feedback loop causing exponential growth
on the other hand an increase in the
number of susceptibles
will lead to a higher number of newly
infected people
which accordingly will then lower the
number of susceptibles
making this per definition a balancing
feedback loop while we cannot
immediately see this without looking at
the underlying equations
the stock of the susceptibles is
multiplied with that of the
infected to determine the rate of people
becoming infected
therefore this is a non-linear dynamical
system
in a nonlinear system the dominant
feedback loop driving the overall
behavior
can shift with these rather simple
building blocks
it is possible to capture the main
drivers of the system's complexity in a
concise
and flexible way the beauty of system
dynamics really is
that we have managed to smuggle
differential equation models into social
science applications
without getting caught but even for an
experienced engineer
the stock and flow metaphor may help to
build intuition
when dealing with differential equations
there's a free system dynamics library
that can be downloaded via the system
modeler library store
it has been out there for some years now
and using it
we can tap into the convenience that
modelica offers
as the example from the wolfram blog
shows we can model market dynamics
using that library in hierarchical
fashion nicely documented on the fly
using system modeler unfortunately
in the system dynamics community the
system dynamics library
and modelica as a modeling language have
not really caught on
let's take a closer look to find out why
the existing approach to system dynamics
using modelica
is not making the most out of what the
language has to offer
and how a new approach might help to
change this
the system dynamics library for modelica
was developed by professor silly
and the students at eth zurich its
visual style is rather close to jay
forrester's original notation
in this simple model we have three
stocks a
b and c a flow component
and a converter component which simply
turns a constant parameter
into a constant input signal stock a
has an initial value of 10 while b and c
are empty
material flows out of a at a constant
rate of one unit per unit of time and we
have connected
the outflow to both b and c which is
perfectly legal with these components
simulating the model with time going
from 0 to 10
in system modeler simulation center
reveals that stock a will be drained
completely
as we should expect but b and c
have both grown by exactly 10 units as
well
since we postulated to concern ourselves
with the transport of some mass in
system dynamics
the seductive ease with which we were
lured into violating
the conservation of meta principle does
not bode too well
to see why this is possible we need to
take a closer look at the model's
connectors
and its internal mechanics
a white triangle modelica denotes an
information or signal output
while the blue triangle conversely
indicates an information input
surprisingly the arrow pointing outward
from stock a
in fact represents information input
while the arrow pointing into the flow
component is an output
the system dynamics library exclusively
models signal flows
its components are always blocks
so the rate information is set by the
flow component and then exported
to a connected stock which internally
uses a block called
integrator to accumulate the flow
the repercussions of restraining
ourselves to signal flows go
further than luring us into violation of
conservation principles
we cannot simply have two flows and then
connect them to the inflow connector of
a single stock
instead we have to add the rates
manually
in the diagram shown we need two
different classes for the stocks
one that has a single outflow and
another one that has a single inflow
and you guessed it we need yet another
class to have a stock with both an input
and
an output connector there's also no
component to represent the byflow
that may go in either direction
unfortunately
all of this forfeits many advantages of
the cyber physical modeling language
modelica
so let's go about system dynamics
modeling in a different fashion
in this simple model of a company's
production chain some kind of durable
good
is produced at a certain rate and
accumulates
into our finished goods inventory from
there
the products will be shipped to
customers here anonymously
represented by the installed bay stock
after the average lifetime has elapsed
the goods are scrapped and in our case
replaced the rate of shipping
is simplistically determined by the rate
of scrapping and the rate of first time
purchases
the notation that you see here is
typical for the dedicated
system dynamics modeling tools
let's now make each variable a separate
component by drawing a frame around it
we can now determine the connectors
we need as interfaces between the
components in this model
instead of just using information inputs
and outputs
we will add an a causal physical
connector and call it a mass port
assigning these connectors to the
components in our model is now rather
straightforward
wherever a material flow in form of a
double arrow pipeline
leaves or enters a component we simply
place an a-causal connector
not worrying about the direction of flow
finally we can name the base classes
used in the model according to their
interfaces
there are two classes that only have
signal ports
the information source has an
information output only
while the converter has one or more
inputs
and one or more outputs
components with one or two a-causal mass
ports may have information
inputs and outputs as well here we
distinguish
sources or sinks that have a single mass
port
and stocks and flows that have two mass
ports
note that while we may choose to make
parameters explicitly visible
by using them as an information source
or a constant converter similar to the
approach in the system dynamics library
parameters are often not made visible in
a model's diagram view
instead they are encapsulated with the
global model
or within the component to which they
pertain
working with the base classes from the
new business simulation library
we can now start out to build this
simple supply chain
where we at first ignore repurchases and
instead simply model demand as a step
input from 10 units per month
to 100 units per month parameters
for this first model are made explicit
using constant converters
as before we start
with a source called growth and the icon
clearly shows the internal logic
using the system dynamics metaphor the
source
is connected to a material stock that
cannot become
negative called inventory
we then use a unidirectional flow
component called transition
to reach the material stock installed
base
the component used for the installed
base is a special type of a material
stock called delay n
it indicates a higher order exponential
delay structure
that here as it has an average delay
time of five years while in the system
dynamics notation the presence of a
delay remains hidden
here it is clearly visible
the outflow from the installed base
finally enters a cloud
that is succinctly represented by a
stock icon
with infinite capacity
we have made system dynamics modeling
quite colorful
as you may have noted but there's a good
reason for this
if you take a look at the event-driven
process chain a typical flowchart
notation used for business process
modeling
you will immediately spot the similarity
events are shown in red and the
continuous time analogy is material
being in a defined state
thus our stocks are also shown on red
processes shown in green are state
transitions
working at a certain rate and continuous
time so our flows
are green as well sources or sinks
simply combine a stock with infinite
capacity and the flow
using a converter that for obvious
reasons is called add
2 and making use of the fact that stocks
and flows report
their amount or their rate via
information output connectors
we can finally include the replacement
purchases in our calculation for the
shipment rate
note that unlike the typical system
dynamics notation it is immediately
clear
that we add first time purchases and the
scrapping rate in the model
we do not need to look at equations the
diagram
tells most of the story unfortunately
we committed a serious error in
formulating this model and in simulation
center we will see lots of events being
raised because we try to ship
more than we'd produce we have turned
the inventory
into a reservoir for anti-matter
violating
what the plus symbol on the stock
indicates
to fix the model we can use a policy
component called
first order stock adjustment from the
library
it simply controls the rate of inflow
into a stock in order to keep a desired
level
given the current amount in the stock
and its perceived outflow
here we would like to keep inventory at
100 units
and we assume exact knowledge of the
rate of shipping at any time
simulating the model with a horizon of 5
years reveals
that the blue rate of production quickly
tracks
the rate of shipping shown on orange
i would like to conclude the
introductory example with a final
extension
let's assume that we have 10 initial
customers
for a new product there will be a stock
of potential customers
that we assume to be 250 000
for now there will be no growth for this
potential
furthermore the new product diffusion
will be completely triggered by word of
mouth
in the library there's a diffusion
component that can be used
to compactly model this process called
bass diffusion in marketing which is by
the way exactly the same process as an
epidemic model note that stock and flow
ports contain both
the current stock level and the current
rate for a connection
this enables us to have complex dynamics
without having to
do many additional connections
using parameter input for the diffusion
component
we assume that there will be a contact
rate of 10 people per month
for the customers and that a fraction of
2 percent of these contacts will turn
potential
customers to customers
we could by the way also have used the
switch for the component
to have a variable input for the
parameters shown making the component
very flexible to use
simulating this model in the simulation
center for 10 years reveals
that our production rate will peak
little more than four years after the
product has
released at that time we will have to
produce around
12 700 units per month after about seven
years
there will just be replacement purchases
probably by then
it is really time for a new release
let me conclude this presentation with a
short tour of the main packages to be
found
in the library the basic classes should
by now already sound familiar
in the package stocks you will find
reservoirs used to represent entities
stored in a specific state
processes that move entities from one
stock to another at a specific rate can
be found on the package flows
there are unidirectional and
bi-directional flows
as well as more complex interactions
which allow to model say a lot gavel
terror model of predator prey dynamics
in just one single component sources or
sinks describe growth or decline
processes at a system's border
converters transform information and
also include
lookups to graphically model functional
relations
external information for example time
series data can be entered using
information sources
more advanced components can be found on
the package molecules of structure
a term coined in the sd community to
describe
recurring model structure in this
presentation i used first order stock
adjustment and diffusion from that
package
the package's decision making or policy
and information processing
collect more complex types of converters
the remaining packages collect more or
less complete subsystems
these are categorized according to their
connectors
blocks represent subsystems of control
or management and have no mass ports
incubators are subsystems that only have
stock ports
transceivers are the most general
subsystems think of a factory in a
supply chain
that have stockports as well as flow
ports
actuators finally only have flow ports
to push or pull entities from or to
other subsystems
that's it i would like to point out that
the library will be published together
with the next release of system modeler
in the library store as open source
under the european union public license
feel free to contact me or the people at
wolfram math core
with any further questions and
don't ever use spreadsheets again for
strategic decision making
thank you for your attention
you